[Music]
oprah almost all patience the dish with
600 years of history and that's when
we understood that we had to form a
brotherhood to defend the dish and
spread it skype choices father father
children
[Music]
I call moura and her current president of
brotherhood of tripas à moda do porto
the owner of the historic leader
we make the best trails in this
city 23 amor do porto is a
consistent project between the stomach of the animal is
a warrior isaac's name is a
fat chicken a good show rubbish wine
and a  of meat salpicão is the beans the
carrot takes two hours to make a good
dish tripes of the dish the mere people in
porto and come from far away to eat the
tripe à moda do porto
the reason for our com fred exists and it is not
that the period  complicated that I'm going to
europe in 2001 mad cow disease
the dish almost disappeared turkish you did
n't eat handwritten letters from the port but the
guts need a great treatment and
disinfection and the hard course create a
micro mini ne  no bacteria Cruzes has
more than 15 years there is no
bovine disease and portugal and I would rather have done a
great job and helped is to develop and
preserve the port-style guts and
we currently see 450 meat - we
make a seat every year we donate
guts  and between 3,000 and 4,000 people
[Music]
once a year we have a big chapter it
's the chapter that entered my
new confreres
already in the movie castro the doctor from Santos and
29 years old
today for you to organize in the
gastronomic confraternity of tripas à moda  from porto it
is very important to keep these
traditions alive and it is thanks to the
brotherhood that we will be able to maintain
this legacy in the coming years that I will
give my contribution
[Music]
given our mona techniques to
represent this brotherhood like this one
touches the medal is a little  heavy but we
have to carry the history of writing
sometimes it's not easy on a plate to
last for a while of history in the
people of the port and even then when the mother
breaks and  want to disclose in your history
your gastronomy reserve stimulus porto
we call ourselves 32 when someone calls
tripeiros we did it with great pleasure
[Music]